normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government Mr
ramaswami are you persuaded by President
zelinsky's urgent new plea where do you
stand on more fun I'm absolutely
unpersuaded yes I'm actually enjoying
watching the Ukraine Hawks quietly
delicately tiptoe back from their
position as has Unwound into a disaster
first half of this race I was the only
person standing for it now they're
actually quietly coming around to being
more cautious as they should level with
the American people here Ukraine is not
a paragon of democracy this is a country
that has banned 11 opposition parties it
is Consolidated all media into one state
TV media arm that's not Democratic it
has threatened not to hold elections
this year unless the US Fork over more
money that is not Democratic it has
celebrated a Nazi in its ranks the
comedian in cargo pant zalinski doing it
in their own ranks that is not
Democratic more facts for you that you
won't hear from the mainstream in either
party or the mainstream media the
regions of Ukraine that are occupied by
Russia right now in the Donas Lans donet
these are Russians speaking regions that
have not even been part of Ukraine since
2014 that other people probably couldn't
name those provinces for you Maj fact
and so to frame this as some kind of
battle between good versus evil don't
buy it and I'd like the likes of the the
sharpest of the warhawks on Ukraine
Nikki Haley to have some accountability
and answer do you want to use US
taxpayer money to fund the Banning of
Christians that is actually what's
happening they're using the Ukrainian
Orthodox Church they have banned them
the Ukrainian Parliament just did this
last week supported by our dollars and I
think you owe it to the American people
Nikki to at least this
one Christian Mr
Ram Mr ramaswami thank you we ask the
questions Ambassador
H your take on more fund let the
response let's see the question I'm
telling you Putin and president she are
salivating at the thought that someone
like that could become president they
would love
to this is what I will tell you driving
Russ not the 9s anymore you had your
time to talk the Ambassador has the
floor Ambassador the first thing I'll
tell you is we all remember what that
Thug did when he invaded Ukraine we all
know that half a million people have
died because of Putin and here is a
freedom loving pro-american country that
is fighting for its survival and its
democracy no I don't think we should
give them cash I think we should give
them the equipment the ammunition to win
and I'll tell you if Biden had done it
when they first asked for it this war
would be over let's also remember this
massive cap that is so when you left
Afghanistan in shambles and left them
with a ton of weapons and money it's not
that we left it's how we left when you
look at Ukraine don't think for a second
now everybody wants to move away from
Ukraine they'll want to move away from
Israel a year from now America we wanted
to move no we wanted to move away from
Ukraine right away immediately we wanted
to not ever move in now is the time to
get
partnership Unholy alliance between
Russia Ukraine and China is real there
is a reason the Taiwanese want us to
support the ukrainians it's because they
know that China is coming after them
next there is a reason ukrainians want
us to support Israelis because they know
that if Iran wins Russia wins we have to
see the combination of can't keep fing
Wars all over the world that's her
argument other country is going to want
our money and this other one and if we
don't give our money to this one then
the next one's going to be worried they
won't get our money it's like none of
them should be getting our money it's
boilerplate a couple she was like I
don't want to give them money I want to
give them arms and equipment like how
are you going to pay for that stuff our
money choice this is the price we pay
for being the leaders is do this like
solemn Som he user's name over and over
again he did the Donald Duck and that
flopped so now he's trying to do the I
must be
serious shut upud and they are all
working to support Russia right now my
advice to Chris reason they're doing it
is because dictators work together
people who believe in democracy work
together with all of those that are
standing up for democracy and freedom in
this world and by the way let's remind
every of this
in 1992 this country made a promise to
Ukraine we said if you return nuclear
missiles that were part of the old
Soviet Union to Russia and they invade
you we will protect you he is correct an
American promise1 years old is no
different than an American promise
that's made tonight on this stage we
need to stand by it and those of us who
forget history are doomed to repeat it
and that's right I'm trying to remember
the history of Iraq and Afghanistan
abolute giving in to dictators which is
being suggested on the stage just shows
the immaturity of the approach peace is
not giving into dictators I love how
they think peace and wanting peace is
immature and they're like why don't you
want to bomb more people and kill more
18y olds that's mature any suggestion by
zalinsky or anyone else that we should
that we're going to eventually have US
troops there I can tell the American
people when I'm president that will not
happen we are not going to send your
sons and daughters to Ukraine I am going
to send to our Southern border if you
look at the threats that we Face
terrorists have come in through our
Southern border I'm going to shut it
down I'm going to have the military and
I'm going to deport the people who've
come particularly under Biden who've
come from the Middle East come from all
these places now Biden wants $105
billion UH 60 most of that's Ukraine
including some of it going to pay
pensions for bureaucrats and salaries
that is a totally ridiculous use of
American tax dollars he says he has
money for border to try to do the media
repeat that when you look at it what
most of the money is is money to process
more illegal aliens into this country
how is that solving the problem that's
making the problem worse and what does
he do for the Indo Pacific a pittance
that is the top threat that we Face we
need to bring this war to an end we need
the Europeans to step up and do their
fair share and we need to get serious
about the top threat that this country
faces which is the Chinese Communist
party so if I may respond to the Ukraine
question we are going to go from the hot
Wars in only isep people are calling
apparently yeah I mean Ron is doing a
dance you know he's dancing
between I hate that more than anything
many Republicans believe
chines General Secretary X is an
existential threat to the United States
the flasho is Taiwan for decades and
decades the American Military but
primarily the United States Navy has
deterred an attack attack from China to
the Island state of Taiwan but Ronald
Reagan's Navy of 600 ships is gone now
the question to you is and I'll start
with you Ambassador Haley because you
were in president Trump's cabinet his
goal was a 355 ship Navy that's what he
pushed for he got to 300 it's now at 291
wow is that big enough to deter and if
necessary defeat an invasion of Taiwan
China has the largest naval fleet in the
world they have 350 ships they'll have
400 ships in two years we won't even
have 350 ships in two decades China has
built up their military it's not just
Land Air and sea they're doing cyber
they're doing artificial intelligence
they're doing space America needs to
modernize our military we need to do
everything we can the first thing is you
go and you make sure you have the back
of you backs of Ukraine that's why the
Taiwanese want us to support Ukraine
because they know that sends the biggest
message to China the second thing is we
go to China and we start being tough on
them no more sales
of our American soil to China and let's
take back what they've already stolen
then you go and you to the universities
no more having millions of dollars go to
our universities then we will go and end
all for formal trade relations with
China until they stop murdering
Americans from fentel something Ron has
yet to say that he's going to do and
then we modernize our military when we
strengthen our military when we
modernize it with the focus of cyber
artificial intelligence in space when we
make sure that we have the backs of our
friends whether it's in Israel whether
it's in Ukraine and we should be arming
Taiwan make sure they have the equipment
they need make sure they have the
training they need now there is nothing
China fears more than knowing that
America will have taiwan's back let's
make sure that we show up by making sure
they have the equipment they need ship
are
more now than they ever have
Hypersonic I'm much more concerned with
us advancing in space like let's
dominate space because ships are really
going to be more and more vulnerable
over time with drones and everything
else president G's ambition and if
China's able to be the world's leading
superpower that will affect you and your
family in ways that are going to be very
bad they will export authoritarianism
all around the world as the cost of
doing business they won't post things
like social credit scores and internet
monitoring so this is to this generation
what the Soviet Union was so the post
World War II generation I've already
released a plan we're going to get to
355 ships at the end of the first term
385 ships at the end of the second term
but we're going to have a path to 600
ships over the next 20 years I think the
future freedom is going to be determined
in the Indo Pacific we have a strategy
not with mil not just military but
decoupling from the economy and fighting
them here at home with their cultural
you know Ambassador Haley said somehow I
wasn't doing she welcomed them into
South Carolina gave them land near a
military base wrote the Chinese
Ambassador a love letter saying what a
great friend they were that was like
their number one way to to do economic
development in Florida I banned China
from buying land in this St we kicked
out on our universities and we kicked
the confucious institutes out of our
universities we've recognized the threat
and we've
acted he needs to fire his campaign yes
that's the biggest problem he was a
fantastic has been a fantastic Governor
his
campaign been just a disaster had he
done what V has done which is don't
offend Trump voters don't offend Trump's
supporters embrace them and attack the
corruption and attack the
corruption he would be in such a
different place right now totally
different if they put Will Chamberlain
in charge of his PR and got rid of the
existing
ones would have killed it I mean he'd be
doing such a great job running that
campaign in the midst of trying to back
our strongest Ally in Eastern Europe
we've seeing our resources and our
Weaponry help degrade the Russian
military the Indo Pacific we have real
challenges that long-term threat the
long-term threat is China immediate
threat is our Southern Border in order
for us to have the military to fight
three different con continents at the
exact same time we are going to have to
invest heavily in our military but we're
also going to have to invest heavily in
an industrial base so that we can hit
our objectives from a military
perspective not only with our ships but
also with our air with our planes we are
so old as a military that in order for
us to re-calibrate we're going to have
to invest one of the things I do in my
made in America strategy is we create
more than 4 million new jobs by having
high-tech manufacturing come back to
America decoupling from China so that we
focus our attention on creating that
Industrial Revolution that will Beary
should not fired unvaccinated
soldiers Tim Scott should not be on
stage right now yeah no no keep him as
Senator you know if if they want him
there in South Carolina seems like a
nice guy but he's so out of his dep how
big would the fleet get first answer is
end the toxic divest to invest program
for people who don't know about that
we're decommissioning ships in the South
China Sea the foundation of war is
economics rebuild our defense industrial
base at home but here's the Dirty Little
Secret our actual defense industrial
base depends on China for the supply
chain for the F-35 jets for the ships
that we're building think about this why
are we stockpiling that if it isn't to
actually be strong against our enemy
China we depend on them for that just
like we depend on them for
pharmaceuticals just like we depend on
them for semiconductors so here's why we
can't get tough with China it's because
we depend on them for our modern way of
life and we have to declare economic
independence from our enemy that's the
Declaration of Independence that Thomas
Jefferson at the age of 33 would have
signed and today if you were alive
that's the Declaration of Independence
that I will sign as the next president I
do have to recognize Ronda s was cor
about acknowledging Nikki Haley's tough
talk when she was ambassador to the UN
calling China our great friend bringing
the CCP to South Carolina what he left
out though Ron and be honest about it
there was a lobbying based exemption in
that bill that allowed Chinese Nationals
to buy Lin within a 20m radius of a
military base lobbied for by one of your
donors so I think we have to call a
spade a spade we need politicians who
are independent of the forces that
increase our dependence on China my
message to xiin Ping is this you are
done buying land in this country you
will not donate to universities in this
country us businesses won't expand into
the Chinese market until you play by the
same set of
rules sounds
rules accountability for the co 19
pandemic financially which unleash hell
on the world we have to hold them
accountable you have a number that
almost sounds like policy for loving
your increase our Naval capacity by at
least 20% over the course of the next
several years
uhoh be able to meet our Aus agreement
standards right now we are at risk of
not even being able to meet our Aus
standards with with Australia and the UK
so what we need to do is have a plan
that reverses the trajectory of the
divest to invest program to buy 20% over
the next three years Governor Christie
you know my first observation Hugh is
that nobody answers your Hugh get person
observation is these three in the middle
think they're the enemy I know China is
the enemy and that's what we should be
focused on so let's be real clear the
nuclear submarines in this United States
Navy is the greatest deterrent to
Chinese aggression and that is the first
place I would go to increase American
Naval power our nuclear submarines are
able to move stealthly quietly and
effectively and if we are going to deter
China from invading Taiwan the only way
we're going to do it is to make sure
that they don't know whether how many
nuclear submarines from the United
States of America are in the South China
Sea and in that area and ready to strike
on them if they decide to move on Taiwan
and so we as our first priority need to
go directly to our nuclear subprogram
Hue and we need to increase it
drastically that would be priority
number one ships would come next but to
me the ships are secondary Choice here
the the submarines are the single most
important thing that we could be
deterring that we could be using to
deter China but the other thing we can
do to deter China is to let them know
that the blood money they're spending
for Russ in Ukraine right now will not
be effective that we send Putin home
with his tail between his legs and make
them understand that the same fate waits
for them if they decide to move towards
Taiwan with a more aggressive nuclear
subprogram will be able to make that
threat real thank you Governor we're
going to take a brief pause now and
we'll be back to the Republic we need
more subs to have a a legitimate threat
uh nuclear threat I we we already have
Subs uh I don't think that it's a
terrible idea to have more nuclear subs
um just won't play and keep in mind the
Chinese have nuclear subs on our West
Coast I don't think I don't know if
that's actually true I would be shocked
if they didn't are there more people
watching the Trump rally no no 7,700 and
the GOP debate's about 70k but I can't
it's probably because the it won't play
The Stream won't play so wild yeah yeah
it we can uh start recycling 95% of our
spent nuclear fuel through closed system
recycling systems and just have so much
more I mean nuclear powered submarines
is definitely the with nuclear warheads
ready nuclear power in general is such a
massive opportunity for America they
haven't talked about graphine which
we're going to start if we're going to
reindustrialize our Navy it's going to
be with lightweight graphine materials
and hydrogen fuel and nuclear power
these are the things that none of them
got specific I know they're limited with
time and that's why president usually
has science advisers to advise them on
those things but we AB are you gunning
for that jobi in yeah yeah yeah gunning
I like that that metaphor yeah I'm going
to help the the US Navy become the
greatest on Earth I want sh that can go
from underwater into outer space and
back again oh I'm with you on that I see
I told you my concern is space you know
as long as we're able to get up there
I'm happy man super lightweight
submarines that can go up into orbit uh
energy Tech we need uh better propulsion
technology better better energy
conversion technology things like that
yes yeah like what
plutonium I don't know I defer the the
nuclear that stuff that stuff's very
heavy remember nuclear subs are just you
know it's it's just a a it's just to
heat water you know it's just a steam
engine so the the tech for nuclear sub
to make the the rotor spin is going to
be significantly different to what would
be necessary to actually have propulsion
that can defeat it's easy because
they're floating like pzo electric power
where you actually can vibrate
substrates to create electrical current
that's so you don't actually need steam
like that's the next step of energy
production I don't okay I don't I don't
know how that would trans trans out to
space it would be lighter weight than
having fuel on board or something or or
like hydrogen fuel well somebody already
knows how to do it have you guys seen
these videos uh from you know the UFO
files the government's been like slowly
putting out that some of these have gone
into the ocean they visually confirmed
like the pilots have seen them go into
the ocean and come out I mean somebody's
figured it out I don't know who it is I
I don't it's it's not hard to make a an
air and SE vehicle yeah so we already
have planes that can land on uh uh on
water you could probably I don't think
it's a great feat of engineering to
figure out how to make something that's
to submerge it and then come back out
you know what I mean I think the speeds
they're doing it and everything is
really what they've been impressed by
that's the biggest problem is if you're
talking about getting into space like
breaking Earth's gravity is is really
really really hard yeah you know you
have to be it's 20,000 M an hour is the
speed you need to be to get out of Earth
gravity they've got those spin launch
systems have you seen those where
they'll get it spinning really fast and
you can get materials up really easy it
slingshot basically spins around and
then boom straight up in the air that's
Co cool looks so cool and then another
thing they do is um they they they'll
bring a plane as high up as possible and
launch from the plane so that it cuts
down a lot of the energy usage But
ultimately the plan is get everything on
the moon you build a moon base this is
what it was this is the emis project
right yeah you build a moon base so that
you slowly transport energy and
materials up there and then you can
launch for further missions yeah they're
working on the space elevator on the
moon lift Port is the company with
Michael Lane he used to work at Nasa and
they're they're aiming at doing it on
the moon first because of the low
gravity it's easier to get the elevator
up and running thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8:00 pm and become a member over at
Tim cast.com for uncensored membersonly
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next
time